The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, in
that case, let's
start-- I want to begin by
giving a quick review of where
we were last time.
And then we'll
pick up from there.
Today's lecture,
the main subject
will be the-- see if this works.
The main subject will
be the spacetime metric,
which is what we'll
begin by talking about.
And later, I hope we'll be
doing the geodesic equation.
Last time, we began by
talking about open universes.
And we got to open universes
by way of closed universes.
And we started with this
Robertson-Walker form
of the closed
universe metric, which
holds for k greater than 0
describing a closed universe.
And then we said if we want
to describe an open universe,
we can use the same equation,
but let k be less than 0.
And this metric has a name,
the Robertson-Walker metric,
which applies for k
being positive, negative,
or 0 as a special case.
When k is 0, this just
becomes the Euclidean metric
written in polar coordinates.
So it's a flat space
for k equals 0.
Then we addressed
the question of,
why should we believe this
as a proper description
of an open universe?
We know how to write it.
And we could make it look
a little better perhaps
by introducing a kappa,
which is minus k.
So that kappa could be
positive when k is negative.
To answer that question,
we had to define
what criteria we had in mind for
the metric we were looking for.
And what we're trying
to do is write down
a metric that will describe
a homogeneous and isotropic
universe.
Because from the
beginning of course,
we said that those are
the key properties that
describe, to a
good approximation,
the universe that we live in.
So what we want to know
is that this metric
is homogeneous and isotropic
when kappa is positive
and k is negative, the new case.
For the closed universe case,
we already knew those things
because in the
closed universe case,
it's obvious because we know
we got it from a sphere.
And a sphere is clearly
homogeneous and isotropic
from the start.
So looking at this metric
for kappa positive,
we see immediately that
it's obviously isotropic,
at least about the origin.
Because if we just
sit at the origin
and looked at different
angles-- theta and phi--
the theta phi dependence
of this metric
is simply given by
that expression.
And this is exactly the
metric of the surface
of a sphere whose radius happens
to be a of t times little r.
And we know that that
sphere is isotropic.
It doesn't look
manifestly isotropic
because when you put
theta phi coordinates
on the surface of a sphere, you
choose a north pole and measure
everything from that.
So your coordinates
break the isotropy.
But you know perfectly
well that the sphere itself
is completely isotropic.
So isotropy is settled
about the origin.
And if we're soon going
to prove homogeneity,
it's enough to know that it's
isotropic about the origin
because homogeneity
will demonstrate
that all points are equivalent.
So if it's isotropic
about the origin,
we will ultimately know that's
isotropic about all points.
So homogeneity is
the hard thing.
How do we convince
ourselves that this metric
is homogeneous?
Now, if we look at it, it
doesn't look homogeneous.
It certainly looks like
the origin is special.
That was the case for
the closed universe
Robertson-Walker metric as well.
So it's certainly not decisive.
But it also doesn't prove that
it's homogeneous by itself.
So we have to figure
out how we would
prove that it's homogeneous.
And here, we only
sketched an argument.
We didn't really go
through it in detail
because it gets messy.
But I think logic of
the argument is clear.
And it's, I think,
rather persuasive
that this argument would
work if you wrote out
all the equations.
So let me go through
the argument again.
We start by thinking about
how we would demonstrate
that the closed
universe was homogeneous
in a mathematical way using
algebra rather than words.
And if we wanted to prove
that the closed universe was
homogeneous using
algebra, we would set out
with the goal of trying to show
that any point-- and we'll let
r sub 0, theta sub 0, pi sub
0 denote an arbitrary point.
What we'd like to
show is that any point
is equivalent to the origin.
And by equivalent to the
origin, what we really mean
is that we could define a
new coordinate system where
this arbitrary point
would become the origin,
and the metric would look just
like it looked to start with.
And then this new
arbitrary point
will be playing
exactly the same role
that the origin played
in the first place.
So we're looking for
a transformation which
will map r0, theta 0, and phi 0
to the origin while maintaining
the form of the metric.
And we really know
how to do that,
because we know
from the beginning
that this universe is
homogeneous because
of the way we constructed
it as the coordinization
of the surface of a sphere.
And the sphere is
manifestly homogeneous.
You can rotate any point on
the sphere into any other point
just by performing a rotation,
which certainly does not
change anything about
the metric on the sphere.
So we want to basically
take advantage of that fact.
And we could imagine--
and we can even
carry it out if we have to,
but I only want to imagine it.
I want to imagine constructing
a map from r, theta,
and phi to some new r prime,
theta prime, phi prime.
We want to map the entire space.
But we want it to
have the property
that the special point--
r0, theta 0, and phi 0--
gets mapped to the origin.
So we want to construct
this general mapping which
has the property that
our special point is
mapped to the origin.
And we can do that
in three steps.
And they're shown
schematically here.
We first simply transform
from our r, theta,
and phi coordinates to the
four coordinates x, y, z,
w that we, in fact, started
with, the four coordinates
that describe the euclidean
four dimensional space in which
this three dimensional
sphere is embedded.
Once we have the four
dimensional space,
we can perform
euclidean rotations
in that four dimensional space.
And we can perform
any rotation we want.
And we, in principle, know how
to write those out in detail.
And we can choose the rotation,
which maps r0, theta 0, and phi
0, keeping track of where it
went, to the values of x, y.
Z, w that will
ultimately correspond
to the origin of our
coordinate system
when we get back to r prime,
theta prime, and phi prime.
So we can arrange
for that to happen
by choosing the
right rotation here.
And once we've
rotated, we can then
define r prime, theta
prime, and phi prime
in terms of x prime, y
prime, z prime, and w prime
in exactly the same way as
we did in the first place
when we didn't have primes.
We just used the
same formulas again.
And that will ensure that
the metric and r prime,
theta prime, and phi prime will
be just the metric that we've
had, because it's determined
from the euclidean
metric in the four dimensional
space in exactly the same way.
So this does it.
And we could, in principle,
do it all in detail.
And we would get a
concrete expression
for r prime, theta
prime, and phi prime
in terms of r,
theta, and phi that
would have the property that we
want of mapping the arbitrary
point that we chose to become
the origin of the new system.
So the point is that
once you've written
that all those
equations, you know
that they work for k positive.
But in the end,
you'd just have a set
of equations that define
r prime, theta prime,
and phi prime in terms
of r, theta, and phi.
And those equations are
just as valid for k negative
as they are for k positive.
And the fact that the
metric will be unchanged
is also just as valid for
k positive and k negative,
because the metric is
really just determined
by derivatives of the new
coordinates with respect
to the old coordinates.
And those are all just
algebraic expressions.
And if an algebraic
expression is
an equality for
one sine of k, it
will be an equality for
the other sine of k.
So I think we have good
faith-- although it'd
be more convincing perhaps
to actually write out
all equations, but I
think we have good faith
that the same map will
work for k less than 0.
And by "work," it means that it
will show that any point could
be mapped to the origin
by a metric-preserving
transformation, which is the
key thing, which is what we need
to show that the space
is actually homogeneous
even though when we write
in these coordinates,
it doesn't look homogeneous.
So does that make
sense to everybody?
Are there any questions
at this point?
The next thing we
did-- ah, I'm sorry.
I guess we-- point
out that we're not
going to actually
show this explicitly
because the algebra
involved in the steps
does get very complicated.
I wanted to mention
a few other facts
about this
Robertson-Walker metric.
One important fact, which we
will not show-- to show it
would take approximately
another lecture.
It's not an incredibly
deep mathematical fact,
but it requires
establishing some formalism
to handle descriptions
of curved spaces
without yet knowing what
the metric is going to be.
But in any case,
it can be shown--
and we're going to store
this in back of our heads--
that any three dimensional,
homogeneous isotropic space can
be described by this
Robertson-Walker metric.
Now, it's important to
realize that that does not
mean that the Roberson-Walker
metric is the only way
to write down a metric for
a homogeneous and isotropic
space.
You could choose different
coordinate systems
that would make
things look different.
But the point is that for any
homogeneous and isotropic three
dimensional space, it is always
possible to assign coordinates
who make the metric the
Roberson-Walker metric, which
means that if you understand
the Robertson-Walker metric,
you need to understand
anything else.
Any homogeneous
and isotropic space
can be described this way.
Next, we pointed out last time--
and did a short calculation
to demonstrate for ourselves--
that for k greater than 0,
the universe is finite.
And that's clear
from the beginning,
because it was described
as a surface of a sphere
and the surface of
a sphere is finite.
But for k less
than or equal to 0,
the variable little r of
the Robertson-Walker metric
can become arbitrarily large.
That by itself does not
imply that the space
is necessarily infinite.
But you could also
calculate the distance
from the origin as a
function of little r.
And that, you can show,
becomes arbitrarily large.
And that does mean that
the space is literally
infinite in size.
So for the flat case
or the open case,
the Robertson-Walker metric
describes an infinite universe.
And next, so we mentioned--
and this is a homework problem,
or an optional homework
problem on the current set--
that the
Gauss-Bolyai-Lobachevsky
geometry is actually simply
the open universe in the two
dimensional case rather
than three dimensional case.
So in the language of the
Robertson-Walker metric,
I think it's much
easier to describe
than in the coordinate system
that Felix Klein invented.
But it's the same space.
And on the homework
set, you can work out
the mapping between
the Klein coordinates
and the Robertson-Walker
coordinates
to see that they're
the same space.
Any questions?
OK.
Next, we changed subjects and
started talking about the topic
that we'll be continuing
now because we did not
finish this discussion--
the discussion
of how to go from
this space metric
that we now understand to
the spacetime metric, which
is the fundamental quantity
of general relativity
and which we'll be using to
describe our model universes.
Time ends up not playing
an important role
in what we'll be talking about.
But nonetheless, it
is an important part
of the basic formalism
of general relativity.
And for some
questions, it's crucial
how time enters the metric.
So we will discuss how
time enters the metric.
So we want to generalize the
metric from a spatial metric
to a spacetime metric.
And the first
thing that means is
that we want to understand
the relativistically invariant
interval between two
points in spacetime.
A point in spacetime is
also called an event.
And we begin with
special relativity
because that's what all
this is a generalization of.
In special relativity, one can
define the Lorentz invariant
distance between two events.
Here, the events are A
and B. And the coordinates
of those events are xA,
yA, zA, and tA for event A.
And as you would
obviously guess,
xB, yB, zB, and tB for event
B. And the Lorentz invariant
interval between those
events is s squared sub AB.
And the first and most important
thing about this interval
is that it is Lorentz invariant.
That is, you can compute
it in any inertial frame,
in any Lorentz frame, and
it will have the same value
even though the
different pieces of it
will have different values.
The differences will cancel out.
And in the end, when you
calculate the sum of these four
terms to make s
squared sub ab, you
will find they'll have the same
value in any Lorentz frame.
And we're not going
to show that fact.
But we're going to use that
fact, a very well known fact
to anybody who studied special
relativity in a reasonably way.
It's important to think
a little bit about what
the meaning of this
peculiar quantity
is that mixes space and time.
And I think the easiest way to
think about the meaning of it
is to think about special cases.
And it's a real number which
could be positive, negative,
or 0.
And those are the
special cases I
want to think about--
positive, negative, or 0.
So if s squared is
positive, it means
that the separation
between the two events
is what's called spacelike.
It's dominated by
the spatial term.
And if that's the
case, it's always
possible to find a
frame where the two
events are simultaneous.
And in that frame,
s squared is just
the square of the distance
between the two events,
so has a clear interpretation.
It's just the distance
in the Lorentz frame
in which they occur
simultaneously.
Similarly, if s
squared is negative,
it means it's dominated
by the negative time term.
And in that case, the
separation is called timelike,
as you'd guess.
And it has the property
that it's always
possible to find a Lorentz frame
in which the two events occur
at exactly the same
point in space.
And in that frame,
s squared is equal,
up to a factor of
minus c squared,
to the time separation
between the two events.
So s squared measures the time
separation between the two
events in the frame at which
they happen in the same place.
And s squared is
actually minus c squared
times the time
separation squared.
And finally, if s
squared is 0, that's
called a lightlike separation.
And it means that the
two events are separated
by just the right distance so
that if a light pulse left one,
it would just arrive
at the other location
at exactly the
time of that event.
So the two events
could be joined
by a light pulse that travels
at the speed of light.
And that's the significance
of s squared being 0.
OK, any questions?
OK-- actually, I don't
want to that slide.
We'll get back to that.
OK, that finishes the
review of last lecture.
Now, what we want
to do is continue
talking about
spacetime intervals
and how we fit that into the
metric, which will ultimately
describe distances in
both space and time.
So I'm going to work on the
blackboard for awhile now.
So the formula that we're
starting with-- and we'll put
dot dot dot here and minus c
squared tA minus tB squared.
The dot dot dot means the
y term and the z term which
you can probably imagine are
there without my writing them.
From this expression, knowing
that what we want to do
is to take advantage of these
geometrical ideas introduced
by people like Gauss
which described distances
in terms of
infinitesimal distances
between infinitesimally
close points,
we can write the
analogous equation
for an infinitesimal distance.
And that becomes ds
squared is equal to dx
squared plus dy squared plus
dz squared minus c squared
dt squared.
So this would be the
Lorentz invariant separation
between infinitesimally
separated events.
And this is what
we're going to try
to generalize to our
curved space situation.
So this would be the metric
for special relativity.
It's called the
Minkowsky metric.
OK, now I want to move
into the general relativity
generalization of this idea.
And general relativity
makes use of the idea
that Gauss originally suggested
that distances should always
be quadratic functions of
the coordinate differentials.
So we're going to keep that.
Einstein kept that.
Now, in talking about
coordinate differentials,
we should emphasize here
that in general relativity,
unlike special
relativity, coordinates
are just arbitrary labels
for points in spacetime.
In special relativity,
coordinates actually
measure distances
and times directly,
which is why the
metric is so simple.
You don't really need the
metric in special relativity.
The coordinates
themselves will tell you
the distances and the times.
But in general relativity,
that will not be the case.
There's no way to do
that for a curved space
or a curved spacetime.
So in general relativity,
the coordinates
are just arbitrary labels
of points in spacetime.
And to know anything
about actual distances,
you have to look at the metric.
The coordinates themselves don't
tell you the actual distances.
This immediately
implies something
about the kinds of
coordinate transformations
that you might want
to think about.
In special relativity,
we have a privileged set
of coordinates, namely the
coordinates of Lorentz frames,
of inertial frames.
And the physics is simple when
described in terms of those
coordinates.
In principle, you can
use any coordinates
you want, even in
special relativity.
But you never do, because the
physics is so much simpler
in the inertial coordinates
that there's never
any motivation for using any
other coordinate systems.
But in general
relativity, there is
no privileged coordinate system.
And it's very common to make
all kinds of transformations
of coordinates in the context
of general relativity.
And the formalism
is set up so you
could make any coordinate
transformation you want,
and it's just thought
of as a relabeling
of the points in space and time.
And the formalism of
general relativity
works for an arbitrary labeling
of points in spacetime.
So in general relativity,
any coordinate transformation
is allowed.
But there's an
important feature of
these coordinate
transformations--
is that when we make a
coordinate transformation,
we're always going to readjust
our metric so that ds squared
between any two nearby
spacetime points
has the same value
in the new coordinate
system that it had in the old.
We will always change
our metric to reflect
our changes of coordinates.
So ds squared must have the same
value in any coordinate system.
So the statement
is that ds squared
is coordinate-invariant.
OK, to define what we mean by
ds squared, which if you notice,
I haven't quite done yet.
It's going to be, of course,
the analog of what we've
been talking about in
special relativity.
In special relativity, we
did have this special class
of observers, inertial
observers, observers
whose measurements
of length and time
really corresponded
to the inertial frames
and whose observations
are related to each other
by Lorentz transformations.
It's important to
start out by asking
is there any class of
observers in general relativity
which might play the same
roles-- the observers that
sort of define the measurements
that you want to talk about.
And it's clearly a little
bit more complicated
in general relativity.
The inertial observers
of special relativity
are characterized
by the statement
that there are no
forces acting on them.
So they just travel at
a constant velocity.
And you can always go to a
frame where that velocity is 0
and you an talk about the rest
frame of any inertial observer.
In general relativity,
we need to distinguish
to some extent between
non-gravitational forces
and gravitational forces.
Non-gravitational forces,
like say, electrical forces,
are treated in
general relativity
in a way that's fundamentally
similar to the way
that such forces are treated
in special relativity.
But gravity is treated
totally differently.
Gravity is really just
going to be described
by the metric of spacetime--
by the distortion of spacetime.
And we already know, by
way of simple examples,
that if general
relativity actually
works to describe the universe
that we've been talking-- which
it'd better or we'd
be in trouble--
we have a system
where if we just
look at the co-moving observers,
each co-moving observer has
no non-gravitational
forces acting on him.
He's just sitting still
as far as he's concerned.
But nonetheless, these
co-moving observers
are accelerating
relative to each other
as the universe expands and
as that expansion changes
its expansion rate, which
we've already calculated.
So if there's going to
be any observers that
are going to play the role
of inertial observers,
it's presumably going
to be a class that
includes these
co-moving observers.
And the question
of whether or not
there are gravitational
forces acting
on the co-moving
observers ends up
depending on your point of view.
Each co-moving
observer would think
that there's no gravitational
forces acting on him.
He would just be standing still.
But he would see all these
other co-moving observers
accelerating relative to him.
So he would say that there are
gravitational forces acting
on these other observers.
So gravitational forces
in general activity
becomes
coordinate-dependent ideas.
And the Hubble
expansion is one example
of that where every co-moving
observer would consider himself
to be unaccelerating
but would see
all the other co-moving
observers accelerating.
The other famous
example, which is
part of the original motivation
of general relativity,
is the famous Einstein
elevator, which
is also discussed
in Ryden's textbook.
If we have an
elevator box, we could
imagine letting
the elevator fall.
There was a rope there,
but somebody cut it.
And the elevator's now falling.
And we have a person in it.
And the person in my--
the version of the story
that I have in
the lecture notes,
the person's holding
a bag of groceries.
And if the elevator
is falling freely
and we ignore any air resistance
or any other kind of friction
so the elevator's falling
at exactly the freefall
rate, inside the
elevator, everything
will be falling with
the same acceleration.
The person could lift his
feet up off the floor,
and he would just hover there.
He would feel no gravity
pushing him towards the floor.
And similarly, he could let
go of the bag of groceries,
and they will just appear
to float in front of him
as long as he's
undergoing this freefall.
So the effects of gravity
have been completely removed.
On the other hand, from
outside the elevator,
if we use the frame of
reference of the Earth,
we said that there
very definitely
is a force of
gravity acting here.
It's just acting the
same on all the objects.
And this gets elevated into
the equivalence principle
of general relativity.
And maybe before
I annunciate that,
I should consider
the other case here.
This is one example
of how things work.
A similar situation can
involve the same elevator,
but this time,
let's have it just
be sitting on the floor of the
building that it's located in.
In that case, the
person inside would
feel himself pushed against
the floor by gravity.
If he was holding
his bag of groceries,
he would notice he has to apply
force to the bag of groceries
to stop the groceries
from falling to the floor.
He would say that
he's being acted
on by the force of gravity.
That would be the
natural description.
But we can consider
an analogous case
where we have the same elevator
in empty space with a rocket
ship up here that I
didn't allow myself
room to draw tied by
cables to the elevator.
And if the rocket ship
accelerated with acceleration
little g, the person
inside the elevator
would feel himself pressed
against the floor in exactly
the same way as you would here.
So again, we have
a situation where
there's gravity in one case and
no gravity in the other case,
but no difference in what
the person inside would feel.
And that is what becomes this
principle of equivalence, which
says that the physics
of the accelerating
frame of the elevator in
that analogy-- so this
is accelerating frame
but with no gravity--
is equivalent to feeling
the gravitational field
of the Earth.
In short, if you were
living inside the elevator,
you cannot tell which of those
two pictures describe the world
that you're actually part of.
And this is a very
deep principle.
It has very strong implications.
It really does mean
that everything
you'd ever want to know
about how gravity affects
physical systems can be
described by understanding how
accelerations affect
the physical systems.
So it reduces the
questions of what gravity
does to just understanding
what happens when you're
in an accelerating
coordinate system.
OK, this also opens the
door for the question
I began with-- is there a
special class of observers
here?
And we can identify a
special class of observers.
But the special class
is not observers
which have no forces
acting on them, which
is what we would have said
in special relativity.
But rather, the
special observers
are the observers who have no
non-gravitational forces acting
on them, like the
co-moving observers
in our model of the universe.
But gravitational
forces, you could never
say if they're there
or not because they're
always there in some frames
and not there in other frames.
So we have no control
or no way of making
any frame-invariant statements
about the force of gravity.
So what we'll be interested
in as our primary observers
and which we're going
to use to define things
in this class of observers with
no non-gravitational forces--
and those will be called
free-falling observers.
And they're called
free-falling because you
have no way of knowing
whether they're just observers
for which there is
no gravity, which
would be an example of
a free-falling observer
by our definition.
But the situation
is indistinguishable
from this one,
where free-falling
has its obvious meaning--
that the guy there
is falling relative
to the Earth's frame.
But he's freely falling.
And therefore, he does not feel,
relative to his environment,
any forces whatever.
Now, I should emphasize that
this equivalence principle
holds only in small regions.
In principle, it only holds
in infinitesimal regions
because there are, in
gravitational systems, what
we call tidal effects,
where a tidal effect simply
means that the
gravitational field is never
completely uniform.
And if the gravitational
field is not uniform,
you do not completely cancel it
by going into the accelerating
frame of the elevator.
But in any infinitesimal
region, you
can always cancel the
effects of gravity
by going into a properly
accelerating frame.
And that's what the
equivalence principle says.
OK, are there any
questions about that?
OK, this being said-- it was
a long prelude-- we can now
define what ds squared
is supposed to represent.
And the answer is simply that ds
squared has the same meaning as
in special relativity except
that inertial observers are
replaced by
free-falling observers.
OK, so let's review
what exactly that means.
It means that if ds
squared is positive,
it means that there
will always be
a class of free-falling
observers for whom those two
events will occur
at the same time.
And ds squared will be the
distance between those two
events as measured by those
inertial observers-- bah,
I said "inertial"--
free-falling observers.
And similarly, if ds
squared is negative,
it means there will be a class
of free-falling observers
for whom those two events will
occur at the same location.
And ds squared will measure, up
to a factor of minus c squared,
the time separation squared
between those two events.
And it will again be the
case that if ds squared is 0,
it will mean that the
two events are separated
by just the right distance
so that a light pulse can
travel from one to the other.
OK, any questions about that?
It's was kind of a
long-winded discussion.
But I think it does
pay to actually
understand what df ds means
rather than just to write down
a formula for it and say
that's like special relativity.
OK, having said all
this, our next goal
is to figure out how time enters
the Robertson-Walker metric
to give us a spacetime
metric instead
of just a spatial metric, which
we already have written down.
And I'm going to
write down the answer
and then describe why that
has to be the right answer.
I think it's the easiest
way to handle it here.
So the right answer is that when
we incorporate time and think
of this as a metric
for spacetime,
ds squared is going to be
minus c squared dt squared
plus a squared of t
times dr squared over 1
minus k r squared-- right now,
it's just the same spatial part
that we had before-- plus
r squared d theta squared
plus sine squared
theta d phi squared.
End parentheses.
End curly brackets.
So all I've done is
I've added a minus
c squared dt squared
term to the metric.
Now, why is this
the right metric?
I'm going to first consider
two special cases, which
will verify some
of the terms there.
And then I want to
also discuss why
there aren't any other
terms besides the ones
that we know have to be there.
So first, let's just consider
the case-- case one will just
be dt equals 0.
If there's no time separation
between the two events,
then we're only interested
in spatial separations.
And we've already
talked about how
to describe spatial
separations in a way which
makes the description
homogeneous and isotropic.
And we said that this is the
most general way of describing
spatial separations that
are in a space which
is homogeneous and isotropic.
So from what we said previously,
this has to be the answer.
That's how we describe
homogeneous isotropic spaces.
So when dt vanishes,
it just reduces
to the case we've
already discussed.
Simple enough.
Case two, which involves a
little bit of new thinking--
suppose dr equals d
theta equals d phi
equals 0 so that
only time changes.
OK, this describes the situation
about our co-moving observers.
They're sitting at fixed
spatial coordinates
and evolving in time.
And we've already said that the
thing that we call cosmic time
is simply time as
measured by the wrist
watches of our
co-moving observers.
So t, if you want t to
be cosmic time, which
we do-- we're trying to describe
a metric for our spacetime
as we've already described it.
We're now just trying to
write a metric for it.
So t should be cosmic time.
So t should be the
time as measured
on the wrist watches of
the co-moving observers.
And that's exactly
what this metric says.
It says that if
ds squared defines
the measurements of our
free-falling observers, which
is what we said is the
definition of ds squared,
that it is just equal
to minus c squared
times the change in
the coordinate time.
And coordinate time
means cosmic time
because that's the coordinate
system we're using.
So putting in the
minus c squared
dt squared term is the
only way that it can be so
that the wrist watches of
our co-moving, free-falling
observers measure the same thing
that the coordinate measures,
which is what we defined cosmic
time to be in the first place.
So I think that
justifies this term.
And notice, if you had
any coefficient here other
than c squared, there'd
be a multiplicity
offset between what the wrist
watches of your observers
are measuring and what
cosmic time is ticking off.
And we're not allowing that,
because we define cosmic time
to be the time measured
by the wrist watches.
OK, so that takes care
of these two cases.
And I think it implies
that these terms have
to be here in exactly the
form that we've written.
And we could stop
now and pretend
that we've solved
the whole problem.
But I always like to be what
I consider to be thorough.
So I like to sort of
imagine the questions that
could pop up if people
were inquisitive.
So you might imagine that you
have some difficult roommate
who says, why can't I
put some other term,
and what else could there be?
The only thing that
we've left out here
are terms that
involve products of dt
with either dr, d
theta, or d phi.
So what about terms like
the product of dr times
dt or d theta times
dt or d phi times dt?
Question mark.
So one possible answer
is I looked in a book
and it wasn't there.
But that's not the best
of all possible answers.
It's good to
understand why things
are in books and why
other things or not.
So you might want to
construct an argument of why
these terms have to be absent.
And the reason why those
terms have to be absent
is because if they were there,
they would violate isotropy.
Roughly speaking, the
notion is that if you
have a dt times some
d spatial coordinate,
that singles out a certain
direction in spatial
coordinates space because dr
is not the same as minus dr. Dr
points in a certain direction.
To be more explicit
about that, in the notes,
I discuss a thought
experiment which basically
gives a concrete
realization of the asymmetry
that I just discussed.
So to see how those terms
explicitly violate isotropy,
we can imagine a
thought experiment
where we start by thinking about
some particular point in space.
And we'll give it coordinates
r, theta, and phi.
And I'll assume r is non-zero.
We could then imagine that two
people sitting at this point--
and in the Lewis Carroll
spirit, I call them
Tweedledee and
Tweedledum-- can decide
to do an experiment by first
synchronizing their clocks.
And they might as well
synchronize t cosmic time,
let's say.
And then, one of them can go off
in the direction of positive r,
and the other can go off in
the direction of negative r
at the same coordinate
velocity, which I'll call v.
And by coordinate
velocity, I mean dr dt,
because that's the simplest
thing to talk about here.
It many not be the same
as the physical velocity,
but we don't care.
It'll be the same
for both of them.
And the experiment will be
that they will each travel
until there's some-- until
cosmic time-- they're
passing a lot of cosmic
time clocks as they travel.
And they agree to travel
until cosmic time ticks off
until some chosen final time.
And when they each
finish the experiment
by noticing that the cosmic
time clocks now read t sub f,
they will look at
their own watches
and see how much time elapsed.
So they're basically
measuring time dilation--
how do their wrist watch
times, when they move,
differ from cosmic time.
And the point is that if we
have a dr dt term in the metric,
these people get
different values
because the time
that they measure
will be what they
call ds squared,
up to a factor of
minus c squared.
And that will include
this dt dr term.
And dr for one of them will
be the coordinate velocity
they chose times d cosmic
time, the amount of cosmic time
interval they travel for.
They've agreed on that
before they take off.
And for the other, dr
will be negative vc times
dt, so cosmic.
So this term will give
a different contribution
to the ds squared that each of
these two entities, Tweedledee
and Tweedledum, will measure.
And therefore, they'll
be measuring different ds
squareds, and that means they'll
be measuring different things
on their wrist watches.
And that means they have
an asymmetry in directions.
By going one direction
or the other,
they could determine
whether their time dilation
will be increased or decreased.
And that, if our
universe is isotopic,
should not be possible.
And therefore, if we want to
write a metric which describes
an isotropic universe, we
have to omit the dr dt term.
And a completely
identical argument
implies that we have to also
omit d theta dt and d phi dt.
So isotropy implies dt
dr term is not allowed.
Because otherwise, we would have
a Tweedledee Tweedledum time
dilation asymmetry,
which we're not
allowed to have an
isotropic universe.
OK, any questions about that?
OK, if you have no
questions about that,
now we're ready to go
onto our next topic.
Now that we've described
the metric of our universe,
there it is-- the full
Robertson-Walker spacetime
metric for a homogeneous
and isotropic universe.
The next thing I'd like to about
is how do we calculate motion
in a metric in the context
of general relativity.
And our treatment here
will be completely general.
We'll learn how to calculate
motion in an arbitrary metric.
And we'll in fact use
the Schwarzschild metric,
which describes spherically
symmetric objects like stars
or even black holes
as an example.
But our real purpose
is to understand things
like motion in the universe.
And I guess at this point, I
am going to-- load up screen.
OK, good.
OK, I'm going to just use the
equations from the lecture
notes.
This particular
calculation involves
a lot of long
equations, so I think
doing it on the blackboard would
probably be a bit too tedious.
So I'm instead going to
just lift the equations
and talk about them directly
from the lecture notes
themselves.
So what we're interested
in is thinking
about a geodesic in
some arbitrary metric.
And we're going to start with
the simplest possible example
of the two dimensional spatial
metric of the same kind
of spaces that Gauss and
Bolyai and Lobachevsky
were talking about using
this notation of differential
geometry of thinking of a metric
in terms of coordinates, which
in this case, we'll
initially call x and y.
It will generalize perfectly
straightforwardly to spacetimes
because all the
ideas are the same.
But it's easiest to start out
by thinking about you're simply
talking about
measuring distances
in a two dimensional space.
A geodesic is defined as a line
between two points in space
which has the property that
the length of that line
is stationary with
respect to any variations.
Stationary means the
first derivative vanishes.
Now, in this two
dimensional space example,
our stationary lines will
also always be minima.
That is, you can minimize the
distance between two points
by finding the
shortest possible line.
There is no longest
possible line.
And there aren't any saddle
points either, I don't think.
So I think in this
case the minima--
the stationary points will
always be minimum I believe.
But in general, when we
have spacetime metrics,
especially when things are
not even positive definite,
these geodesics, the
stationary lines,
can be either maxima or
minima or saddle points.
So you should imagine that all
those possibilities are there.
However, the
equations we'll derive
will really just
be the equations
that say that the first
order difference vanishes.
If you vary the path a
little bit to first order,
the length does not change.
And that will be true for
maxima, minima, or saddle
points.
We won't have to care in
deriving the equations.
So we start by imagining
a metric like that.
And the first
thing we want to do
is just adopt a better
notation for the metric.
And there are two improvements.
The first is to
number the coordinates
instead of thinking of
them as different letters.
So instead of talking
about x and y,
we're going to talk about
x super one and x super 2.
Now, these 1's and
2's have the danger
of possibly being
confused with a power.
We probably never write
x to the first power,
but you might write x super 2
and think of if as x squared.
Many times we, of
course, do that.
So one always has to hope that
the context will make it clear
what that index refers to.
But here, these upper index
objects-- those superscripts
are just indices.
They're not powers.
You might wonder why we tolerate
such a crazy notation when
we could have written
them as subscripts.
And then there would
not be this confusion.
But the answer is that
in general relativity,
one does make use of both
subscripts and superscripts
in a slightly different way.
And to some extent, you'll see
that in what we'll be doing.
So it's useful in
general relativity
to have two kinds of scripts.
And the only places that seem
to exist are up and down.
So they're superscripts
and subscripts.
And one simply
hopes that there's
no confusion with powers.
OK, so step one is
number your indices
and to number your coordinates.
And then instead of writing
that the sum of three terms
that we had-- and of course,
it gets to be much more.
If you have four coordinates, it
would be 16 terms or 10 terms,
depending on how
you collected them.
But instead of
writing that mess,
you can write it using
the summation notation.
Sum from i equals 1 to
2, sum j equals 1 to 2
of g sub ij of the
x-coordinates times dx i dx j.
And when you sum over i and j,
you're summing over 1 and 2,
which means you're
summing over x and y.
And the sum includes
the x, x term,
which is now called
the 1, 1 term.
And the y, y term
which is now called
the 2, 2 term,
and the x, y term,
which is now called the
1, 2 or the 2, 1 term.
And those are identical
to each other.
And they just get added.
So that shortens the
notation considerably.
But then there's one
further simplification
that was actually introduced
by Einstein himself.
And it's always called the
Einstein summation convention.
Notice that in this
equation, the letter i
appears twice as an
index-- as an upper index
there and as a lower index
on the metric, g sub ij.
And the Einstein
convention is that whenever
you have a repeated index where
one is upper and one is lower,
you automatically sum over them
without writing the summation
sign.
The summation sign is implied.
So then this equation get
simplified to that equation,
which is the form that
we'll actually be using.
And that's as about
as simple as it gets.
OK, so far, that's
just notation.
OK, now what we want
to do is to talk
about a path between two points.
And we want to discuss how
we're going to describe the path
and how we're going to derive
the equations that will tell us
that this path has the
minimum possible length, which
is what we're trying to do.
We're trying to find the
equations that tell us
when a path has an extreme
value of the length.
So to describe the
path itself, we're
going to imagine
parameterizing it, which
means we're going to think
of a function xi of lambda,
where xi-- remember,
xi means 1 and 2.
It means specifying one both x
and y as a function of lambda.
So this is really two
functions of lambda.
And this function
of lambda is going
to show us how the point
that traces out this path
varies from point A
to point B. And we'll
allow it to vary as a
function of this parameter
that we've introduced, lambda.
And we'll adopt the
convention that lambda
is 0 at one end and lambda
sub f at the other end.
So xi of 0 will be required to
be the coordinates of point A
If we want to start at
some specified point A,
we want to end up at
some specified point B.
So we'll insist that the
coordinates evaluated at lambda
sub f are xi sub B. And
as long as xi of lambda
is a continuous function,
which we will also insist on,
then xi of lambda will describe
a path from A to B, which
is what we're trying to do.
OK, to apply the
metric and write down
an expression for the
length of this path,
that's what we want to do next.
And then we want to
figure how to extremize
that expression for the length.
First step, we need to get
an expression for the length.
So the metric is
written in terms
of infinitesimal separations.
So we want to imagine
dividing this path up
into little segments, each
corresponding to some d lambda.
Each little segment goes from
some lambda to some lambda
plus d lambda, where d
lambda is infinitesimal.
And the change in the
coordinates over that interval
are then just the
derivative of xi
with respect to
lambda-- remember,
we have this function, xi
of lambda-- times d lambda.
This will give us
the differential
coordinates between
any two neighboring
points along the line.
Then ds squared is
defined in terms of d xi.
And we just plug this
formula into the expression
for ds squared in terms of
the infinitesimal separations.
So we have the metric.
And then where we had
previously just d xi,
now we have d xi d
lambda times d lambda.
And similarly, where we
previously had just d xj,
now we have the derivative
of xj with respect to lambda,
again, times d lambda.
So we have two
powers of d lambda
appearing in this expression.
ds itself will be the
square root of ds squared.
In this case, we
are talking about
positive, definite distances.
So we can take the square root.
So we put a square
root sign over it.
And now, we have only
one power of d lambda.
And this describes the
length of the segment that
goes from lambda to lambda plus
d lambda, the length as defined
by the metric.
The full length of the
line is obtained just
by integrating that from 0
to the final value of lambda.
So equation 540
here is what we're
looking for-- the expression for
the length of the line in terms
of the parametrization
that we've chosen.
OK, any questions
about that formula?
OK, next step-- and here's where
things get kind of complicated
with the algebra,
although I think
the ideas are still
pretty simple.
The next step is
to figure out how
we determine when
that expression is
at its minimum value.
How do we determine when the
path has the right properties
that we found the
minimum length?
So to do that, we want to
imagine varying the path.
We want to consider comparing
the length of the path
that we're thinking about to
the length of an arbitrary
nearby path.
And to do that, we can introduce
a little bit of extra notation
here.
Here's the point xA
Here's the point xB.
x of lambda is the path
that we're thinking about.
And we're asking the
question, is this the path
of minimum possible length?
And to do that, we're
going to compare it
with an arbitrary nearby path.
So the arbitrary
nearby path is what's
called x tilde in this diagram.
It starts at the same point xA
and ends at the same point xB.
But along the way, it deviates
by an infinitesimal amount
from the original path.
And we're going to parametrize
that by equation 541a here.
The tilde path will be
equal to the original path
plus a parameter that I'm going
to introduce called alpha times
a function wi of lambda,
where wi of lambda
is really an arbitrary function.
And I've introduced this
extra parameter alpha
just so I could say
in a simple way what
it means for these paths to
be infinitesimally close,
which just means that if alpha
has an infinitesimal value,
the two paths are
infinitesimally close.
And the function wi,
we'll think of being
a perfectly finite function
with values like 2 and 5,
not values that are
infinitesimally small.
OK, with this
parametrization of our paths,
we want to impose one
important criteria, which
is that the two paths are
supposed to start and end
at the same points, A and B.
And that means that this w super
i that describes the
derivation between two paths
have an advantage at
those two end points.
Or else, the paths aren't going
from the same starting point
to the same ending point.
And, certainly if you
move the endpoints,
you can always find
a shorter path.
There's no geodesic if you allow
yourself to move the endpoints.
So we insist therefore
that wi of 0,
which is wi at the
first endpoint, is 0.
And similarly, wi of lambda
sub f at the other endpoint
is also 0.
That's what we insist on.
OK, now having set
up this formalism,
we can now write down
a very simple equation
that says this path
is an extremum.
The path is an
extremum if ds d alpha
is equal to 0 for all
choices of wi of lambda.
OK, if it's an extremum, it
means any small variation,
any small variations are
proportional to alpha.
Any small variation
produces 0 derivative.
So ds d alpha should equal 0.
And that should be the case
for any possible deviation
if we really have found the
minimum possible length.
OK?
OK with everybody?
OK, now, it's mostly just a
lot of gore to get the answer.
The key step will be a
crucial integration by parts
that you'll see in a minute.
But let's just go through
the algebra together.
I'm going to define an auxiliary
quantity a of lambda alpha,
which is just the metric
times the derivatives
of the functions.
The path length of the
deviated path-- these
are tilde functions here.
So a is the integrand
for the length
of the perturbed
path, the tilde path.
So s of x tilde is
just the integral
of the square root
of a, d lambda.
OK, now we need some pieces
to carry out our derivative.
So I've introduced a few
auxiliary calculations here
that we can then put
into the big calculation.
We're going to need the
derivative of the metric
with respect to alpha.
Now, the metric does not
depend directly on alpha.
But the metric does
depend on x tilde.
It's evaluated at
the point x tilde
for any given value of lambda.
And x tilde depends on alpha,
because remember, x tilde
was equal to the original
path plus alpha times
this wi, the derivation.
So it's a chain rule
problem to figure out
what the derivative of gij
is with respect to alpha.
So it's the derivative
of gij with respect
to xk times the
derivative of xk tilde
with respect to alpha-- just
straightforward chain rule.
And the derivative of x
tilde with respect to alpha
is just this function, w super
i, or in this case, w super k.
That's what defines
the deviations.
So this is our result,
then, for the derivative
of gij with respect to alpha.
Then, we apply that to
differentiating s itself,
finding all the alpha's
inside that square root.
And scroll up a little bit so
we can see the definition of a.
a consists of gij times
the dx's themselves.
And the dx's themselves
depend on the alphas.
So we're going to get terms
coming from differentiating
those with respect to alpha.
And we get a term coming
from differentiating
the gij with respect to alpha.
So the whole quantity
in the integrand
here has a square
root operating on it.
So the derivative of the
square root of a quantity
is 1 over the square
root of the same quantity
times the derivative
of the quantity,
just differentiating
the 1/2 power of a.
So that gives us a 1/2 and
1 over the square root of a.
And then inside here,
we have the derivative
of a with respect to alpha.
And one of those terms,
we've already calculated.
It's this multiplied
by dx i d lambda dx j
d lambda, which come
along for the ride.
And they lose their
tilde because we're
trying to calculate the
derivative at alpha equals 0.
So once we differentiate one
factor with respect to alpha,
we evaluate the other
factors at alpha equals 0.
So that's what we've done.
We've evaluated the other
factors at alpha equals 0.
And then, when we
differentiate dx i tilde
with respect to d lambda, we
just get DWI d wi with respect
to lambda.
And dx j d lambda comes
along, now evaluated at alpha
equals 0.
And similarly,
the second term is
where we differentiated the
second factor here with respect
to alpha.
And we differentiate
with respect to alpha,
we bring down the w.
So this becomes dx i d
lambda dx j d lambda.
So this is the expression.
And now we want to
simplify it a little bit
and figure out how to write
down an equation which
tells us when it's actually 0.
So first, we want to
simplify it a little bit.
And I guess I want
to-- do they fit?
Almost.
What I want to argue is
that these last two terms
are really equal to each
other up to just rearranging
the indices.
Remember, i and j are
just being summed over.
So we could have called them
any letter we wanted, and they
would still just
be summed 1 and 2.
And in particular,
we can interchange
what we call i with
what we call j.
And then, these two terms
would become identical.
And we're allowed to do
that because these are just
what are called dummy indices.
They're just names of indices
that are being summed over.
And you get the
same sum no matter
what you call the index
you're summing over.
So those terms can be combined,
giving us just 2 times
either one of those
two terms we can keep.
And now, we only two
terms in our expression,
which is not bad.
But things are still
a little complicated.
And what makes them complicated
at this point, which
is what we have to get
rid of, is the fact
that w occurs as a multiplicity
factor in the first term.
But w is differentiated
with respect
to lambda in the second term.
And when it's written
that way, there's
no direct way you could see
what properties w has to have
or the other terms
have to have so
that the expression vanishes.
But the crucial
trick for handling
that particular issue-- and
it's the only real issue
in this problem.
The rest is just straightforward
or sometimes tedious
manipulations.
The key step is to
integrate by parts
to turn the derivative
of w expression
into an expression that is
just multiplicative in w.
And the miraculous thing is
that for the situation we have,
there are no boundary terms
that arise from that integration
by parts.
So here's integration by parts
spelled out in gory detail.
We're going to use the
famous formula that
says that the integral
of udv is equal to minus
the interval at vdu plus
the product U times V
evaluated at the two
endpoints and subtracted.
So this is just the
standard formula
that defines
integration by parts.
The U is the term that starts
out not having derivatives
and later acquires derivatives.
So that's the 1 over
root a gij dxj d lambda
of this-- this is the quantity
we're trying to calculate.
And the du will just be--
I'm sorry-- dv will just
be the factor which
is a differential
in the original expression,
d wi d lambda times d lambda
we're going to let
be equal to dv.
So this u and this dv give
us the original integral.
This integral is the
same as the integral
we're trying to evaluate.
Now when we integrate by parts,
we apply a derivative to U
to write down dU, which means
it's just the derivative
with respect to lambda of the
quantity in brackets times
d lambda.
That's the du.
And dv is just
easily integrable.
D is equal to wi.
Now, the important thing is
to look at the boundary term.
Because if the boundary
term went on 0,
we might not have
accomplished anything.
But the boundary term is 0
because the boundary term
is the product of U
times V, and V is wi.
And wi vanishes at both
boundaries that remember,
was just the condition that
the path goes between A and B.
When you vary the path,
you don't vary the points A
and B. You only vary
the path in between.
So wi vanishes at the endpoint.
So that means that v
vanishes at the endpoints.
So that means if the
product of U times V
vanishes at the end points.
And that means our boundary
term, our service term,
does not contribute.
So we turned the original
integral into another integral
where now wi appears as
the multiplicity factor
and it's no longer
differentiated.
Lots of other things get
differentiated in the process.
But wi gets to sit by itself.
And that now makes it easy
to combine these two terms
and see under what
circumstances the sum vanishes.
So the integral, after
we make this integration
by parts on one
of the two terms,
becomes this expression
where now, the w's
are always multiplicative.
And by rearranging the names
of these dummy indices--
as we initially have it, w has a
superscript k in the first term
and the subscript i
and the second term.
But one could rearrange
these dummy indices--
we could name them anything you
want-- so that in both cases,
w has the same index.
And then you can factor it out.
And then you get this
marvelous equation,
which is now very close
to being an equation
that we're prepared
to deal with.
The question we
want to address now
is under what circumstances
does this vanish for every wi?
Now, if we only know
that it vanished
for some particular
wi, then we would not
be able to say very much.
Because it's very
easy for an integral
to be nonzero all over the
place, literally everywhere
except maybe at some
isolated points and still
integrate to 0.
It could be positive
in some places,
negative in other places and
zero only at crossing points
and still integrate to 0.
But if this is going
to vanish for any wi,
then the claim is that the
quantity in curly brackets
has to vanish identically.
And I think the
best way to prove
that is to say that if
the quantity in brackets
did not vanish
identically, then you
could let wi be equal to
the quantity in brackets.
Remember, if this is
non-zero for any wi,
we have a contradiction
because we're
going to require this
to vanish for any wi.
So if the quantity in
brackets were nonzero,
we could let wi be
the same quantity.
And then we would just have the
integral of a perfect square.
And then clearly, the
integral would not vanish.
So that shows that if
the quantity in brackets
does not vanish, the
integral does not
vanish, at least for some wi.
And that means that
if the integral's
going to vanish
for every wi, which
is what we're trying to impose,
the quantity in curly brackets
has to vanish identically.
And that's our conclusion.
So that implies--
and I guess here
is where we're going to stop.
But we get to the
famous boxed equation.
And this really is-- we'll
simplify it a little bit
afterwards next time.
But this really is the result.
The geodesic equation
is that equation,
which is just the equation
that the quantity that we
had in curly brackets vanishes.
So if the path that
we've chosen has
the property that
these derivatives are
equal to each other-- and
notice it depends on the metric
and it depends on the path.
Because you have dx d
lambda appearing everywhere.
And x of lambda is the path.
But if this equation
holds, then that path
is a stationary point.
It's an if and only
if statement as long
as paths are continuous.
That is the geodesic equation.
It tells us whether or not
our path is the minimum.
And next time, we will
simplify it a bit.
And we'll look at
examples and understand
how the formula works.
So I'll see you folks
again next Tuesday.